en este vídeo hablaremos de todas las
distintas maneras en que las moléculas
pueden ser transportadas para atravesar
la membrana celular el transporte quizás
más básico el transporte más pasivo de
los transportes pasivos
es la difusión simple si hay una
molécula lo suficientemente pequeña por
ejemplo no se digamos que esta es una
molécula de oxígeno es pequeña no tiene
carga ni polaridad esta molécula será
capaz de difundirse a través de la
membrana a favor de su gradiente de
concentración pero cuando empezamos a
hablar de cosas con carga o cosas más
grandes entonces éstas ya necesitan
ayuda para atravesar la membrana el
primer tipo de ayuda es solamente
permitir que las cosas se muevan a favor
de su gradiente de concentración a esto
le vamos a llamar difusión facilitada y
tenemos un vídeo completo donde se
explican en qué consiste la difusión
facilitada recuerdas es uno abrir
túnel y dejar que las cosas se muevan
justo por ahí a favor de su gradiente de
concentración vimos esto con los canales
de potasio donde el potasio se acumula
en el interior celular debido a la bomba
de sodio potasio déjame ser más claro
este de aquí es el interior de la célula
y este dakar es el exterior de la célula
t
y este equipo es el exterior de la
célula
este es el interior y entonces el
potasio se va acumulando justo por aquí
hasta que estos canales permiten que el
potasio se mueva a favor de su gradiente
de concentración sin embargo será
detenido debido a su carga ya que el
exterior es más positivo que el interior
y bueno esto ya lo mencionamos en otros
vídeos
lo importante es que observes que este
es solamente un túnel ya veces este
túnel puede estar cerrado como en estos
casos y solamente se abrirá cuando algo
lo active y esto lo vimos cuando
hablábamos de neuronas las neuronas
mandan señales a través de iones que son
liberados por canales dependientes del
voltaje
una vez que el voltaje llega a un cierto
valor el canal se abre y luego como hay
mayor concentración de sodio en el
exterior que en el interior el sodio
puede atravesar la membrana moviéndose a
favor del
diente de concentración el tipo de
transporte que hacen estos canales se
considera un transporte pasivo es la
difusión facilitada donde recuerda que
permites que las cosas se muevan a favor
de su gradiente de concentración y aquí
lo puedes ver con el potasio aquí
tenemos una mayor concentración una
mayor concentración de potasio y aquí
una menor menor y en este caso cuando
hablamos del sodio pasa lo contrario
aquí tenemos una mayor concentración de
sodio mientras que aquí abajo tenemos
una menor
una menor concentración date cuenta que
este se mueve a favor de su gradiente de
concentración y al sodio le pasa lo
mismo es por ello que se mueve en esta
dirección hay mayor concentración de
sodio en el exterior de la célula que en
el interior de la célula gracias a este
canal que tengo aquí se mueve a favor de
su gradiente de concentración ahora
hablaremos del transporte activo
recordemos que el transporte pasivo no
requiere de energía para hacer que las
moléculas se difundan solo se trata del
movimiento de las moléculas a favor del
gradiente de concentración en el
transporte activo para que una molécula
se mueva en contra de su gradiente de
concentración
estamos ya sea usando directamente
energía o estamos usando la energía
obtenida por un transporte activo
anterior primero hablaremos del
transporte activo primario porque es un
poco más fácil de entender aunque
realmente ninguno estanco
pero primero vamos a ver este bien si
estuviéramos hablando de células de
animales el mejor ejemplo para este tipo
de transporte es la que realiza la bomba
de sodio potasio esta proteína es súper
importante porque es ya establece el
voltaje de la membrana en reposo o mejor
debería decir porque ella establece el
potencial de la membrana en reposo el
gradiente de concentración que establece
esta bomba también es muy importante
bombea iones de sodio hacia el exterior
de la célula en contra de su gradiente
de concentración es decir afuera hay una
mayor concentración de iones de sodio
pero la bomba de sodio potasio continúa
bombeando iones hacia el exterior para
hacer esto va a necesitar a la molécula
de atp para que de ella obtenga adp y un
grupo fosfato
es decir hidroliza el atp por esta
función
se le conoce como una app asa es una
enzima que ayuda a romper el atp y la
energía liberada por esta hidrólisis la
utiliza la bomba de sodio potasio para
bombear el sodio al exterior de la
célula mientras que el potasio lo bombea
al interior lo bombea al interior y como
veremos el sodio que es bombeada al
exterior forman energía potencial porque
empieza a construir un gradiente
electroquímico que posteriormente puede
ser usado por el transporte activo
secundario del cual hablaremos en unos
minutos bueno esta bomba sodio potasio
está en las células animales pero
tenemos algo muy similar para otro tipo
de células para células de plantas
hongos protistas y bueno procariotas es
la parte
de assam de protones o también conocida
como bomba de protones esta bomba hace
lo mismo que la bomba de sodio potasio
pero en lugar de bombear iones en dos
direcciones bombea solamente los
protones hacia el exterior celular en
contra de su gradiente de concentración
entonces hay una mayor concentración
afuera que adentro y pese a ello
continuará bombeando a protones al
exterior y para lograr eso lo que hace
es usar atp para cambiar su conformación
de una manera adecuada debido a su
función se llama una atp asa de protones
mientras que por su función nuestra
amiga la bomba de sodio potasio también
se le conoce o se le nombra atp asa de
sodio potasio a estas 2 atp asas nunca
las vas a ver en la misma célula por eso
debería de poner aquí una línea muy
especial porque estoy hablando desde las
distintas
de aquí la vas a encontrar en células
animales mientras que esta otra la vas a
encontrar en células de plantas hongos y
protistas pero ambas usan energía
activamente es decir ellas usan atp para
transportar cosas en contra de su
gradiente de concentración y por eso lo
llamaremos transporte activo ahora bien
debido a que fueron establecidos estos
gradientes electroquímicos estos se
pueden utilizar para hacer otros tipos
de transporte activo y esto va a ser a
lo que conocemos como el transporte
activo secundario y este dibujo que
tengo aquí es mi representación de un
importador este de aquí es un importador
de sodio glucosa y lo que hacen es mover
el sodio a favor de su gradiente de
concentración
este gradiente fue establecido por la
bomba sodio potasio entonces el sodio se
mueve a favor del gradiente de su
concentración justo para camps esto es
lo que va a utilizar el importador de
sodio glucosa va a utilizar esta energía
que de hecho puedes visualizar como una
cascada que hace girar un molino de agua
más o menos así para transportar tanto
en sodio como la glucosa y la glucosa va
a ir en contra de su gradiente de
concentración si te das cuenta aquí
tengo una mayor cantidad de glucosa
mayor y aquí una menor menor y lo que va
a pasar es que la glucosa va a ser
transportada en contra de su gradiente
de concentración ya que hay mayor
concentración de glucosa adentro que
afuera de la célula como mencionamos en
otro vídeo ahora otro ejemplo del
transporte activo secundario es el que
llevan a cabo los anti portadores en el
caso de los co transportadores
portador es lo que va a pasar recuerda
es que las moléculas o iones que
transportan los transportan hacia la
misma dirección es decir uno es
transportado a favor de su gradiente de
concentración con lo que suministra
energía necesaria para que el otro en
este caso en la glucosa sea transportado
en contra de su gradiente de
concentración y por eso lo llamamos un
transporte activo pero en el caso de los
anti portadores las moléculas o iones se
mueven en direcciones contrarias por
ejemplo aquí en este caso tengo el anti
portador sodio calcio aquí el sodio
observa que se está moviendo a favor de
su gradiente de concentración y esto le
suministra energía necesaria para
transportar los iones de calcio en
contra de su gradiente de concentración
para recalcar una vez más cada vez que
algo va en contra de su gradiente de
concentración estamos hablando de un
transporte
y activo transporte activo en este
ejemplo de aquí los iones de sodio se
transportan en una manera contraria a
los iones de calcio observa que estos
van para afuera ya esto se le llama un
anti portador mientras que este de aquí
se le conoce como un importador
ahora bien podrías preguntarte qué pasa
con esta bomba de sodio potasio porque
esta bomba sodio potasio no es un anti
portador y bueno observa esto es muy
importante que los iones se mueven en
direcciones opuestas pero la diferencia
importante es que la bomba sodio potasio
realiza transporte activo primario ambos
iones se transportan en contra de su
gradiente de concentración y un
verdadero anti importador realiza un
transporte activo secundario porque uno
de los iones se mueve a favor del
gradiente de concentración
a esto provee de energía a la otra
molécula para que se mueva en contra de
su gradiente de concentración en fin
espero que este vídeo te haya dado una
visión general de los distintos tipos de
transporte que existen y que te haya
mostrado que tan hermosas fascinantes y
complejas son las membranas celulares y
todas todas estas cosas que tienen que
hacer las células